foreign
kicks us off in Macon Georgia Phil
welcome to the Ramsay show my friend
hey thanks for taking my call absolutely
what's going on
well me and my wife are working on baby
step one uh we purchased a home in May
of last year and between then and now we
switched insurance companies for the
home insurance so our payment would go
down we could bundle some of us that
would just help to help us out a little
bit
um that insurance company that we went
to sent some inspectors out to just kind
of look at the property and they said
our roof was cold now we knew our roof
was on its way out when we bought the
house but the insurance people are
telling us that we have until September
of this year to switch the roof over or
the insurance will last
now I want to get through baby step one
first but my question is once we get
that thousand dollar emergency fund
should we pause uh on baby step two and
just sock money away for the roof or
what would your recommendation be there
absolutely I mean this is what we would
call kind of a storm mode
um number one you got to cover the four
walls before we do anything else food
utilities shelter transportation and you
literally need this roof over your head
and your home insurance lapsing could
put you in a really really dangerous
scenario and so are you going to be able
to cash flow the new roof or the roof
repair what does this look like
uh right now no uh We've caught or
we've cut all the expenses we know to
cut I'm working 60 to 70 hours a week at
my job now my wife will be taking up a
job hopefully a hospital here before too
long she's a registered nurse she's just
waiting on her license to reinstate back
to Georgia great so
after that we should be looking pretty
good she said she's a low ball would be
like 800 extra dollars a month so that
would really help so what's the roof
average cost it looks like it's going to
be about five to six thousand dollars
okay uh we may be able to sweep by a
little under that but I'm not sure
exactly
and what are your minimum payments on
your debt
uh are you able to afford all the
minimum payments and keep all your bills
current
yeah we're we're good right now hers
would just give us a little bit more uh
one more margin to kind of knock down
all that other debt because you should
be able to do this with her extra 800
bucks and you've got I'm guessing a few
extra 100 bucks you could throw with
this roof right now
I want to do that 100 actually yeah okay
so that would put it at about six months
of saving to pay for this roof
which means by the summer time this
thing's done and we're continuing
continuing on with the baby steps
attacking that smallest debt uh next in
baby step two
oh that'll be my plan my plan would be
let's try to beat that goal and say hey
can we get this money saved up by April
by May
so we don't delay our debt Freedom any
longer
all right so I'd be continuing to work
those 60 70 hours let's hope she gets
that job and works as much as she can
let's get a bunch of estimates to see
who who's got the best bid on this job
and then move forward from there
awesome all right thanks so much Phil
appreciate the call